well roger's got it done in spring
training and
he's earned his way here six foot five
23 years old
last year we saw the ability to dominate
pick up the strikeout at times we saw
wildness the bases are loaded three
walks here in the first
the cardinals have had very good success
in miami
matter of fact they have won 12 of the
last 16
down there and that gets through alfaro
edmond will score and it's one to
nothing cardinals
that's got to be caught but you gotta
wonder if he's a little jumpy back there
well yeah i mean he's jake everything he
puts down ends up in a different spot
here
yadier molina two for nine two runs
batted in
and yachty swings and he drives this one
to center field marte is on the run
moving back and the ball's off the wall
goldschmidt scores to young scores
yadier molina has a two rbi double
three nothing cardinals in the first
inning
the three walks have turned into runs
well i said i'd be ecstatic if the
cardinals were able to get three runs
and make those walks hurt
and yachty makes it happen he just jumps
on the first pitch
he sees he really ambushed him you know
roger's probably just trying to get
ahead red ball straight over the head of
marte
who's made some good plays in his career
he's a pretty good outfielder
last season at one point daniel ponce de
leon was sent down to
the minor leagues eight starts but then
he came back
up he was much better what was the
difference for him well i i think that
sometimes he just gets a little out of
whack and
just stay nice and firm and go right at
him just like that
got him with the strikeout and the first
of the night for daniel ponce de leon
tommy edmund at stanford university of
san diego native
1-0 pitch a line drive to short nice
play on the short hop
backhanded by rojas throws to first and
he got him it's a new year it's been a
while
in case you forgot miguel rojas can play
some short stop oh my goodness that ball
by the way
exit velo i'm sure is well over 100
miles an hour and miguel rojas
i mean took a little step back on the
ground
pick that ball it just comes right at
you right there
and a swing and a miss held on to by
molina and the strikeout number two
you know it's it's really funny i don't
know if we'll see that again but you can
tell when a fastball's sneaky
watch him pull his hands at the last
second there goes the runner the pitch
is swung
on and missed he struck him out it's
kind of weird that you build ballparks
and then you
have it bigger smaller short porch long
porch got guys putting up huge numbers
in certain
ballparks and not others and then all of
a sudden you're going to take the ball
and
make it softer and breaks his bat
and it's a base hit out to left went
down to get it
that is one of the things i've noticed
about nolan
is that on his home run against
cincinnati over the weekend watch him go
down to get this adjustments
yes he has the ability to adjust and put
the barrel
on the ball still and 2-2 de young a
swing and a miss he struck him out blew
a fastball by him at 95 miles per hour
how about three in a row on the slider
there
he gets molina a couple of strikeouts in
the third
tommy is batting left-handed for the
first time he had a walk and a run
scored in a ground up while facing the
lefty trevor rogers
the 2-2 hit down the right field line
fair and gone
home run tommy edmond his first of 20-21
and the cardinals add to their lead
against the marlins and it's
four-nothing
a rocket off the bat at tommy edmond
this gets out in a hurry that's what i
was talking about with the
guys who make the adjustment to cut down
in the strike zone a little bit later in
the count
that's that breaking ball you're giving
a guy a whole lot of time
to make an adjustment and bomb away
as sierra bunts it to arenado who looked
at second throws to first too much speed
marlins have two on
now you don't see this too often sure
how this is going to
be ruled but there was a bit of a mix-up
on the defense arenado
thought for just a split second
that he's got to play at second base
this is a hard bun towards arenado he's
coming in fast
[Music]
and that miscommunication i'll tell you
what's going on your shortstop
de young had given up on the play at
second base
bertie and sierra now both in scoring
position
for starling marte full count pitch
he's hitting the air towards center
field it sends carlson back to the track
plenty deep enough to score bernie
moving up to third
is sierra and it's the sacrifice fly for
starling martay marlins are on the board
trailing 4-1
this is you know i i don't think
dickerson's had a whole lot of games
in left field with the windows open you
know what i mean yeah holloway gets the
strikeout of carpenter
broke his bat on a breaking ball went
back to the breaking ball carpenter
fooled
six-time all-star gold schmidt takes
strike three
holloway a nice inning three strikeouts
two innings of work seventh inning
stretched out
set up outside and the pitch is on the
outside corner strike three
birdie didn't like the call they were
both strikes he should not complain
he got a gift then gallegos struck him
out anyway and he's all smiles on the
mount he
knows it was in the same spot roughly
95 miles an hour painted him absolutely
painted
birdie 3-2 again
and a base hit for nola narnado
relief pitching it set down nine
cardinals in a row until this base hit
it's a slider right there that doesn't
get too much movement on it and stays
over the plate this guy just swings
everything back on the hard the inning
rolls on to yadier molina o'neil goes
alfaro's throw
is a little bit high and he came off the
bag
birdie kept the tag on
cardinals may take a peek at it
but the second base umpire ted timmons
was right on top of that one
stolen base attempt by o'neal who
clearly beats the throw
but watch carefully birdie keeps the tag
on him uh
uh yeah what an inch maybe even less
than an
inch just enough great job by john
bertie
i don't want i don't want to see another
slider he's either going to take it
or he's going to hammer it
just what you said wanted it up got it
there
daniel ponce de leon he loves it he's
got a chance for a win tonight it's 4-1
as we head to the night
and a grounder to the young force play
at second and the cardinals take game
one of the series
the final of four to one